did you I don't know did you do this
well when they make you buy like they
made me buy I remember I was so annoyed
about this I was like what what they
made and they wouldn't let you buy a
cheap version of it they made you buy a
book with like the table of all of it
thermodynamic like constants of every
material and I I remember it was like it
was something like a hundred dollars for
this book and if you if you dared bring
not the book they recommend they were
like confiscated off just you just
brought back like a wave of memory did
you have this this thermodynamic table
not this book but just I have I mean it
was same with books yeah University
textbooks in general I remember showing
up on my first day I'm like I'm ready to
take on University I got some spare
change firstly you rock up and they're
like this is the recommended they'll be
like you have to buy yeah yeah yeah
exactly exactly really these are the
textbooks you're going to need and then
you look up the prices and it's like
minimum minimum uh like like first
edition it's uh 80 pounds or some [ __ ]
like that yeah yeah so that's one out of
eight textbooks you need I'm like see
because we had that list as well of like
oh these are textbooks you'll be using
during your first semester yeah
we don't need it if you don't want it
yeah okay I won't the end the third I
make one at least on my exams if you
didn't have that book you literally
couldn't do this so they wouldn't let
you that you had to have that for the
exam if you went into the exam without
it you have to remember every constant
for every material every like grade of
aluminum right right aluminum gross
aluminum
um
you know they would be like different
like it'll be like heat treated aluminum
yeah it would be like this is the
constant yeah this is insane like I
understand the you know like I just
think that why can't you please is that
something you're supposed to remember
no you can't remember the comments well
then why the [ __ ] because they're
[ __ ] well they want you to get used
to the idea of like okay if you're using
this material yeah using like tungsten
you don't need a hundred dollar book to
do it
that would be fine Google it yeah
I mean it's probably a good book and
maybe you would reference it once every
blue I'm sure today there's probably
like an app specifically that just has
like a list of stuff this book was like
editions I bet these materials weren't
changing them gosh I'm sorry anyone
doing any stuff like this is going to
have the resources in the actual
industry like it's just you you have
someone who's going to deal with
material someone is going to deal with
every single cat model yeah you would
put in the material and the type of
material it was and it would do it for
you it wouldn't even it wouldn't like
you wouldn't need to know the constant
wow you definitely like there are jobs
where you have to do this stuff but it's
also like most of the time
it's just like it's it's like you pay an
absurd amount of money to go to college
or university or whatever and then they
they greet you with a hey spend another
thousand bucks yeah you wanted to use to
live on these dumb bugs just because we
refuse to make it any easier for it
which they could yeah and it's just like
I remember this big pile of textbooks
that like I had when I finished my
degree and 90 of them were just
untouched they were like in pristine
condition and I spent like [ __ ] 300
400 bucks getting this show on textbooks
I'm like why the [ __ ] did I spend that
amount of money I'm a broke college
student and you can't resell them yes
because there's additions yeah and
barely anything changes they rearrange
the question yeah yeah oh my God yeah
all right yeah I know it made me feel
bad
I feel bad yeah what do you mean I'm
just realizing that like actual scam it
was like a legit scam yeah yeah like you
I I can't believe it I would like strip
the security off the PDFs like I would
like spend hours and hours trying to
find ways to do that like finding some
python script that someone wrote and
then like and like throwing the PDF in
there like I remember I bought one I I
rented I think I bought it from Barnes
Noble yeah an ebook
then I've used this like python script I
found to like strip all the security off
oh [ __ ] and then I returned the book
back to Barnes and Noble and she had a
copy that I had a copy of the PDF that
was clean and easier to use then send it
around everyone yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
what would this one be in no this is
years ago
I don't remember what book it was
that's good yeah I I really just like I
like doing like making stuff I think
it's kind of like art like I feel I
always used to laugh at like stem I mean
for the stem before like science yeah
and then steam where they like would
throw art into it and I'm like well art
doesn't belong in here yeah and the more
I think about it the more it's like
making stuff is half art oh yeah because
you have to visualize yeah exactly kind
of have this this like in like vision
for it that is quite difficult and it's
very very difficult at times yeah and
it's like why else would you want to do
something if it wasn't art like if you
have to solve a problem that's more
engineering but if you want to do
something that is kind of artistic you
know like I used to try to make like
camera equipment and stuff so I had um
like a really crappy like camera slider
that was like skateboard wheels and PVC
pipes on like little uh
um what are those swively Wheels called
you know like there's only wheels are
the ones that you have on like office
chairs yeah yeah and so you could like
you know slide it back and forth get
camera moves and stuff just like making
like equipment that you couldn't afford
to buy that's cool and uh like I made a
thing
uh you know camera gimbals like the
stabilizer like before any like the
cheap nice ones from DJI came out I
bought one from some kid who had like
screwed it up so I bought it for like
100 bucks because he had destroyed it
and he was just trying to like get some
of his money back so it's like
Craigslist bought it from him uh fixed
it up and then I I programmed a bunch of
stuff and added some Electronics so that
I could have this camera monitor
wirelessly like external to it and so
you could as you pivoted the monitor the
camera that someone else was holding
over here wouldn't move that's insane
um and it's like
I didn't need to do that like why did I
do that it's not because I'm trying to
solve an actual problem I had because
that kind of stuff just like oh this is
cool yeah I just thought it was cool and
so it's like you know that to me made me
realize I think that engineering like
science stuff is more art where it's
like I'm trying to like do things that I
think are cool and interesting and see
if I can solve these problems which is
like not far off from it's like painting
I mean do you guys do any kind of
Hardcore traditional art stuff I don't
know have you tried painting before I
have I think I have negative art skills
yeah I did a little bit when I was young
but I was never good at it yeah well I
mean I feel like most people are bad
yeah there's a reason why I don't do it
anymore yes right like any yeah it's
just like no one's no one's a like I
mean I'm sure there's a prodigy but most
people aren't good we'll beat them up
yeah yeah you know uh YouTube's an art
form
breaking making content right making
content I mean I think being able to
visualize the main content I make art
I think it takes a very creative mindset
to be able to visualize a flow and kind
of have that mind telling a story yeah
yeah that's hard people can't do that
normally and you do have to you do need
practice Yeah the easier it looks like
your video was to make yeah the better
yeah the harder it was to know and a lot
of people exactly don't understand like
they think that we are much more
talented than we actually are like it's
a lot more head banging against the wall
to like get something to be don't say
that I was riding I mean I love you a
lot of the illusions